bonjour à tous et à l'inattendu
exceptionnelle que nous vous proposons
aujourd'hui vous le voyez nous ne sommes
pas à france télévisions dans notre
décor habituel
nous sommes à bry-sur-marne au coeur de
l'institut national de l'audiovisuel
autour de nous 80 ans d'histoire de la
télévision nous contemplent alors
aujourd'hui en plus de nos chroniques
eh bien nous allons vous offrir une
petite visite guidée vous êtes à l'ina
et vous êtes les bienvenus là monsieur
bonsoir je voudrais regarder la france
au fond des yeux
j'aimerais beaucoup que je m'apprête à
tricoter d'accord là-dessus à votre
place je la ramène ont un peu moins mais
si vous ne réussissez pas c'est qu'il
vous manque qu'une seule chose que tout
petit détail les valises à la première
étape de cette visite la rédaction de
l'ina très largement tournée vers le
télétravail en ce moment li na c'est 900
salariés des dizaines de documentalistes
et quelques journalistes vous connaissez
ludivine lopez et camille d'auxerre
bonjour à toutes les deux alors qu'amy
vous avez choisi de revenir sur la
suppression de l'ena annoncé par
emmanuel macron oui ça fait partie de la
réforme de la haute fonction publique la
suppression de l'ena remplacé par lee s
p institut du service public ça fait des
années que l'ena est critiqué notamment
pour son manque de diversité pas de fils
d'ouvriers là bas pourtant quand elle a
été créée en 1945 l'ena devait être
représentative de la société
regardez on a une archive de janvier
1946 quand on présente cette nouvelle
école nous l'avons tous connu ce
fonctionnaire on retrouvait dans toutes
les administrations ce fonctionnaire
sous le harnais est encombré de toutes
les manières de toutes les entraves
d'eau fonctionnarisme déçu est tout cela
a changé pour former ces hauts
fonctionnaires la quatrième république
possède maintenant son école
d'administration qui fournira des cadres
parmi lesquels le gouvernement choisira
ceux qui occuperont les emplois
d'autorité ou l'administration rejoint
la politique c'est plus tueur
fonctionnaires devront avoir les
qualités d'initiative d'énergie et de
décisions qu'exigent ses emplois et
c'est un signe majeur de renouvellement
qu'on ait fait du sport un chapitre de
leur programme
voilà donc les n'a à l'époque former des
champions du sceau de wuzhou très bon
très très bon alors ludivine vous avez
choisi de célébrer un anniversaire
et quel anniversaire quatre-vingt dix
ans les 90 ans de la télé c'est pas les
on est dans l'antre non c'est pas le
vôtre nathanel on est dans l'antre de la
télévision ici alina donc ça tombait
bien
le 14 avril 1931 l'ingénieur rené
barthélémy réussissait pour la première
fois en france à retransmettre une image
entre malakoff montrouge en région
parisienne devant la caméra il y avait
suzanne bridoux en quelque sorte la
première speakerine de la télévision
elle se plier à des démonstrations 1
pour tester la qualité de l'image nous
n'avons que ces photos pour illustrer
cet événement mais en cherchant dans les
archives de l'ina nos documentaliste ont
retrouvé une reconstitution de cet
événement historique
c'était en 1961 c'est un très grand
honneur pour moi d'avoir à présenter la
radio vision ce soir à dos il est mis
notre personnalité
je dois vous avouer que je suis un peu
ému on m'a demandé de faire quelques
gestes susceptibles de vous faire
apprécier la finesse de l'image qui
s'inscrit sur le radio viseur placé
devant vous c'est ce qu'on a tiré le
mans des gestes bien féminin
on a fait du chemin vous avez vu depuis
ses premières images
aujourd'hui la télévision c'est des
centaines d'heures de programmes et
autant de chaînes merci en tout cas pour
cette archive très intéressante les
divines voilà pour l'actualité de la
semaine camille ludivine je vous
abandonne quelques instants je voudrait
emmener nos amis téléspectateurs vers un
lieu hautement stratégique de l'ina
[Musique]
quand on pense sinon on imagine des
étagères pleines de film plein de vidéos
vous n'y êtes pas du tout li na est à la
pointe de la technologie
regardez ce serveur il contient 20
millions d'heures de programmes
numérisés c'est unique en europe c'est
l'équivalent de 120 km d'étagères plein
de films et c'est notre outil de travail
à l'inattendu c'est grâce à ce serveur
que nous préparons le zapping
alors que s'est-il passé le 14 avril à
travers le temps regardez
bonjour
simone de beauvoir est morte
l'information nous est parvenue il ya
tout juste une heure elle est morte à
paris à l'âge de 78 ans aujourd'hui sur
l'aéroport de la havane des centaines
d'américains d'origine cubaine arrive
comme chaque jour de floride pour
retrouver leurs proches
jusqu'à hier il ne pouvait faire le
voyage qu'une fois par an dorénavant ils
pourront se rendre à cuba autant qu'ils
le veulent le face à face entre casseurs
et crs a pris des allures de guérilla
urbaine dans les rues de nantes
les grenats contre les gir 1 à 80 on a
90 de blessés dont certains très
gravement
le dernier tronçon du périphérique porte
d'asnières porte dauphine est maintenant
terminée elle sera bientôt ouvert il
aura donc fallu seize années de travaux
pour que l'anneau de beto entourent
entièrement la capitale sa longueur
totale 35 km l'académie française perd
l'un de ses plus grands écrivains à
maurice druon est décédé à l'âge de 91
ans entré en 66 sous la coupole il était
en quelque sorte la mémoire de ce lieu
prestigieux
il avait composé avec son oncle joseph
kessel le chant des partisans hymne eu
de résistance face à l'occupant nazi
paris roubaix fête ses 100 ans pour le
comique c'est une grande première
iconoclaste puis le chevalier des belles
lettres décorées à plusieurs reprises
coupe le ruban libérateur celui qui a
gagné la course
il aida et les verrières il est là
il ne sait pas encore mais je me ferai
un plaisir de le lui dire bon soir et
demain
[Musique]
voilà je vous retrouve ludivine sur l'un
des plateaux de l'ina dédié à la
formation
il faut le savoir 1 li na c'est aussi
une école on y forme aux métiers de
l'audiovisuel n'apprend l'image on
apprend le montage on apprend le son la
lumière c'est important ça va du bts au
master il ya combien d'étudiants tient
le divine un bayern il y en a 300 à
l'ina vous vouliez me posez une colle
nathanel mais c'est vrai qu'en ces temps
de cosi de vous imaginer à une partie de
la formation qui se fait à distance yale
alors c'est vrai que c'est une
conséquence de la crise sanitaire
l'épidémie a bouleversé notre quotidien
de nombreux citadins ou quitter la ville
envies d'ailleurs envie de s'enfuir
envie de voir autre chose mais où
sont-ils partis ludivine en tout cas
s'enfuir mais c'est la première question
qu'il faut se poser et c'est la question
que pose la revue 6 mois s'enfuir mais
où
alors parmi les destinations il ya bien
sûr les classiques la montagne la mer la
campagne
et puis des destinations un peu plus
insolites comme les bunkers et même
l'espace ces alternatives pour fuir le
tumulte du monde moderne certains y ont
songé dans le passé la preuve en
archives la lune c'est trop près je
préfère partir d'un marché possible
quitter son jardin pour aller vivre sur
mars
cet homme y pensait déjà en 1957 et il
avait beaucoup d'espoir j'espère qu'il
ya des êtres humains et vivent dans ces
lieux avec beaucoup d'intelligence que
la planète aux donateurs en 1965 cet
autre monsieur sabotier de profession se
passer bien des hommes dans sa forêt
bretonne son mode de vie atypique lui
balaie un reportage diffusé sur la
première chaîne de le rpr le sou le moal
vous vivez depuis 82 ans dans la forêt
depuis 82 ans vous faites des sabots
vous devez être le seul le dernier
sabotier à vivre dans la forêt
oui sûrement qu'est ce que vous préférez
vivre dans un village où vivre comme ça
en ferait vivre seule dans la forêt être
coupé du monde moderne c'était aussi le
choix de cette sculptrice en 1996 en
quête de nature et de silences raconté
dans ce reportage de france 3 j'ai
réussi à créer ici le croire un îlot de
de différence je peux vivre à mon rythme
où je peux vivre au rythme à mon rythme
et en vidant couric mobile des saisons
au rythme du temps qui passe
parmi les lieux très recherchés pour
vivre en parfaite solitude l'île déserte
en 1965 au coeur de l'archipel des
écrits ou ce robinson de la manche seul
et c'est difficilement approcher surtout
lorsqu'il s'agissait d'une équipe de
télévision
nous avons dû attendre pendant quatre
heures avant de pouvoir lui parler mais
au bout de 4h apprivoiser il a bien
voulu se laisser filmer autrement quand
elle est objective est loi depuis
combien de temps êtes vous sûr c'était
au mois d'avril et vous ne vous êtes pas
ennuyé depuis
non on est pas autre alternative pour
fuir le vacarme du monde prendre le
large
littéralement la mer c'était le refuge
du navigateur bernard moitessier sa
seule issue pour quitter la société
moderne
on est en train de craquer les gens
deviennent de plus en plus fous ils
seront pas content on est dirigé par des
peurs des gens qui sont mon monde à moi
ça n'est pas la société moderne
ce n'est pas cette société de
consommation ça ne marche pas je ne
marcherait jamais pour ceux qui pleurent
la mer la forêt l'espace les
destinations sont multiples pour fuir le
tumulte des villes et vous quelle est la
route
je vous pose la question nathanaël quel
est votre lieu à vous pour vous
déconnecter alors ça va vous faire
sourire je sais que vous allez en parler
j'habite au milieu d'une forêt située
juste à côté d'à priori ou j'aime bien
les malades et vous avez de la chance
comme on n'a pas cette chance d'habiter
à côté d'un prieuré mais en tout cas
sachez que les citadins plébiscitent de
plus en plus ces retraites dans des
monastères ou dans des couvents c'est
une volonté au delà de l'aspect
spirituel à une volonté de souffle et de
couper justement avec cette vie moderne
et c'était déjà le cas dans les années
90 regarder loin des gîtes d'étape pour
touristes chacun selon le repos la
réfection désiré peut choisir un endroit
plus ou moins isolés comme dans cette
abbaye bénédictine de la pierre qui vire
dans le calme et l'austérité ne doit pas
tromper
l'hôtellerie est souvent complète il
faut parfois réserver sa place six mois
à l'as vence
il est certain qu de plus en plus de
personnes des groupes des familles des
personnes isolées recherche de tels
lieux de bagnères à s'extraire de la vie
quotidienne même en pleine année active
pour se reprendre dans ces lieux où il
rencontre le silence et puis aussi n'ont
pas l'oubli des soucis parce qu'on les
promène avec soin mais on va pouvoir
dans le recueillement
maîtriser davantage sa vie quotidienne
avant d'y repartir
bon avec le candidat il va falloir
attendre un petit peur donc ces lieux
rouvre en tout cas pourquoi ne pas y
songer
merci à vous ludivine pour ses
explications sur cette envie d'ailleurs
[Musique]
voilà dernière étape de notre visite ici
à l'ina dans cet espace ultra moderne un
espace dédié à la communication idéal
pour retrouver notre journaliste camille
d'auxerre et pour accueillir notre
invité isabelle de gaulmyn rédactrice en
chef du journal la croix alors qu'amy le
ramadan vient de débuter les pâque juive
et chrétienne se termine tout juste d'un
des fêtes religieuses
une nouvelle fois perturber cette année
par le cos vide conséquence camille ou
peut-on prier en toute sécurité
devant sa télé c'est là où les croyances
sont le plus en sécurité depuis un an
depuis les jauges qui ont été mises en
place depuis la fermeture de certains
lieux de culte résultat les émissions
religieuses ont des audiences qui ont
bondi à titre d'exemple la messe de
pâques le 4 avril dernier a rassemblé
plus de 900 mille téléspectateurs
isabelle de gaulmyn je rappelle que vous
êtes rédactrice en chef du journal la
croix le succès des émissions
religieuses à la télévision est ce que
cela veut dire que les français
reviennent à la spiritualité
je crois surtout que c'est une évolution
qui est au delà du côté d'ing qui est la
virtualisation la numérisation du croire
on voit beaucoup de maintenant de
confession d'église et serra qui se
mettent sur le virtuel
beaucoup aussi d'autres religions et
c'est vrai que je pense que le coville a
donné un coup de fouet à cette tendance
de fond
vous pensez ce changement il sera
durable pour tous les croyants oui oui
je pense que ce changement il sera
durable il a commencé en fait il ya deux
choses et à la fois le tout les outils
numériques et tout ce que ça me permet
et puis un côté très individualiste une
société qui traduit aussi le fait que
voilà où pratiquer seul et on pratique
seul on choisit sa pratique on choisit
son imam on choisit son prêtre et
finalement on veut pas être dans quelque
chose de très collectif et de très
terroir très paroissiale la mission dit
souvent que les les programmes religieux
les plus anciens à la télévision est ce
que c'est vrai et à quand remonte la
religion à la télé alors oui c'est vrai
nathanaël la première fois qu'on a vu
une messe à la télé c'était en 1948 est
derrière cette retransmission il y avait
un homme le père raymond pichard
c'est un dominicain qui a eu l'idée de
faire entrer donc la religion catholique
dans un écran cathodique celui des
foyers français le petit écran
ça commence dédicace à à richard poirot
rédacteur en chef
ça commence donc avec la messe de noël à
notre dame de paris et cette
retransmission c'est une première
mondiale
les français ont coiffé au poteau de
quelques heures les américains mais chef
un genou droit à l'occasion de cette
première messe télévisée de répondre à
votre interrogation la télévision cette
découverte est génial viens tu as
honneur dans le plan du salut du monde
isabelle de gaulle - les catholiques ont
très rapidement professionnaliser
finalement leur utilisation de la
télévision comment l'expliquer chirac
déjà il y avait une forme d'avant ce qui
était donné par la radio finalement
c'est 10 11 le premier donc s'essayer
longtemps en 1932 qui a commencé à faire
des bénédictions et des messes à la
radio à dire aux catholiques
vous pouvez aussi me re m'entendre par
la radio et donc il y avait cette
habitude là alors après donc la religion
catholique a été assez en avance mais
ensuite elle a été très rapidement
dépassé par les religions protestante
notamment évangéliques et vous savez
qu'il ya un mot c'est des pasteurs telle
évangélique qui est né dans les années
des pasteurs qui finalement avait des
églises complètement virtuel à la
télévision et cette venue des chaînes de
télévision très important société du
label de volume 1 est ce que quelque
part ce n'était pas aussi une façon une
manière de faire du prosélytisme
c'est une province et 3 élitisme si on
veut ou de l'évangélisation si on se met
du côté de l'église
c'est sûr que l'église catholique a
toujours utilisé tous les moyens
modernes de propagande entre guillemets
de d'évangélisation c'est au 16e siècle
à la période baroque ça a été la
peinture c'était aussi
la musique toute la musique religieuse
donc c'est pas étonnant qu'elle utilise
un après ça pose des problèmes parce que
la messe c'est un sacrement où il doit y
avoir une présence réelle
on n'est pas bedie parraine pas qu'on
n'ait pas béni pareil c'est le sacrement
c'est-à-dire le moment où au moins je
l'eucharistie
ces moments là est un moment sacré qui
doit passer par quelque chose de
corporelle par une présence réelle on
peut on peut pas prendre une hostie de
manière virtuelle alors
professionnalisation des catholiques on
a retrouvé une archive de 1949 dans
laquelle justement on voit toute cette
organisation des cars équipe et devant
une église les ingénieurs qui
s'affairent regarder le jour de pâques
un des jeunes prêtres ordonnés la veille
célèbre sa poignée renaissent la
cérémonie est enregistrée par deux
caméras
deux câbles qui tombe le long de la
vieille façade des carmes relie les
caméras aux cars de reportage ingénieurs
et metteur en scène reçoivent et
choisissent les images l'émission est
dirigée vers les antennes des studios et
de là vers la purée pelle bas après
qu'est ce qui se passe une émission à
part entière pour les catholiques
camille oui 1949 et c'est toujours au
père pichard qu'on la doit
le jour du seigneur c'est donc la plus
vieille émission télé la doyenne
hormis au logis t et qui est toujours à
l'antenne 1h30 donc deux catholicisme à
la télé tous les dimanches depuis
soixante dix ans
comment vous expliquer cette longévité
isabelle de gaulle main d'abord je pense
que enfin vous parlez de 1949 à l'époque
95% des français était catholique
baptisé pratique beaucoup étaient
pratiquants donc effectivement là
aujourd'hui on a changé le monde mais à
l'époque on voit bien qu'il y avait ce
besoin
c'était ça semblait légitime qui est une
messe à la télévision
ouais et les suivants ce sont les
protestants qui en 1955 vont donc avoir
leur émission cette fois ça dure 30
minutes
mais regardez ça peut sembler un petit
peu long 30 minutes
[Musique]
m
voilà alors ça passe tout seul ça passe
tout seul bon pourtant on vous a montré
que 20 secondes quand elle fait 30
minutes comme ça de karaoké religieux
s'est fait un petit peu avec les moyens
du bord en fait isabelle de gaulmyn ses
émissions oui elle mais alors là je
crois que c'est très intéressant si vous
allez aujourd'hui dans un temple
protestant
vous n'avez pas de peinture mais pas
d'image c'est une religion c'était là le
propre de la réforme qui est revenu à
une forme assez pur assez austère de la
religion et je crois qu autant les
catholiques sont à l'aise avec l'image
est donc assez logiquement ils sont
devenus à l'aise très rapidement avec la
télévision autant pour les protestants
notamment les protestants réformés qu'on
a en france
c'était quelque chose de très nouveau
donc je crois que c'est à la fois parce
qu'il y avait les moyens du bord avec
peut-être qu'il n'avait pas beaucoup
d'argent mais c'est aussi culturellement
les protestants étaient moins prêts on
va dire que les catholiques à profiter
de cette nouvelle technique d'image
camille autres grandes religions a
basculé vers la télévision au début des
années 60 une émission judaïque
bonjour oui la source de vie et cette
fois encore ça va passer par un homme
josy eisenberg
nous sommes en 62 pour la petite
histoire c'est la fin de la guerre
d'algérie et donc il est l'idée de créer
une émission pour les juifs qui viennent
d'arriver en métropole pour leur donner
une occasion de re créer une communauté
il va animer l'émission quand même
pendant plus de 55 ans et l'objectif
c'était je vous le rappelle donc de
rassembler la communauté juive et
écoutez comment il l'introduit
l'émission chers téléspectateurs bonjour
il y à un mois lors de notre première
émission
et à en croire les témoignages que nous
avons reçu beaucoup d'entre nous ont
pris conscience de leurs liens avec la
communauté et de leur identité juive
ce sentiment a destructibles
d'appartenance judaïsme
nous nous proposons aujourd'hui de
l'éclairer quelques années plus tard il
a réussi à savoir où était la caméra
josy eisenberg
mais il avait de gaulle main est ce que
il a fallu des personnalités comme comme
sera banc pour faire émerger comme ça
les religions à la télévision encore une
fois chaque religion a ses spécificités
la religion juive et une région assez
communautaire 1
donc là il dit aux gens voilà vous avez
une identité juin on va se retrouver en
communauté alors que effectivement les
catholiques eux aussi ils prétendent
parler au monde comme vous disiez ils
font du prosélytisme en tout cas il
évangélise donc il vise l'ensemble de la
planète
les juifs vise les juifs uniquement donc
c'est assez différent comme manière de
parler devant le petit écran chaud alors
vous parler des musulmans kamiz ont dû
patienter encore près de 20 ans pour
avoir leurs émissions oui alors vous
allez voir un ancien programme télé de
télérama de l'époque on est en janvier
1983 une nouvelle émission à part et
isabelle de gaulle main une nouvelle
personnalité va émerger avec cette
émission c'est ghaleb bencheikh
oui ghaleb bencheikh qu'on connaît bien
maintenant et que tu as un intellectuel
musulman et qui c'est intéressant parce
que par rapport à des à priori qu'on
peut avoir sur l'islam la région pas
très intéressantes ou alors uniquement
de terroristes de fondamentalisme et
c'est lui c'est un homme très très très
cultivé et qui va tout de suite faire
entrer dans le texte profond du du coran
l'émission elle apparaît dans les années
80 et c'est pas par hasard finalement
parce que à ce moment là dans la société
française la visibilisation de la
religion islamique
elle augmente et à la marche des beurs
il y a aussi le gouvernement socialiste
qui à l'époque tente d'organiser le
culte musulman avec la création d'un
conseil de réflexion sur l'islam de
france est ce à dire que les émissions
de religieuses elles suivent un petit
peu l'évolution de la société
oui puis finalement le c'est normal
puisqu'on est dans un système de laïcité
il n'y a pas de raison de moins bien
traité une religion qu une autre dont
donc voilà c'est assez logiquement
d'ailleurs la loi de 74 le prévoit que
toutes les confessions et religions
reconnues en france ont un droit
d'antenne alors qui peut varier en
fonction de l'importance de la religion
en tout cas en 91 à qui va-t-on donner
l'émission la nuit du ramadan et bien
c'est à frédéric mitterrand
bonsoir bonsoir et bienvenue à cette
série de quatre nuits où nous fêterons
avec vous le ramadan
ces quatre soirées me concerne
évidemment les musulmans mais en même
temps aussi chacun d'entre nous parce
que le message est le même famille
plaisir d'être ensemble joie de se
retrouver sur l'essentiel est de penser
aux autres
vous voyez ce sont de très bonnes
raisons pour que quelqu'un de france et
d'une confession différente s'y
associent comme vous tous qui nous
regardaient ce soir c'est intéressant ce
qu'il dit frédéric mitterrand isabelle
de gaulmyn finalement une émission qui
devait être pour les musulmans de
premier abord elle est censée s'adresser
à tous les français de toutes les
confessions ça sert à ça aussi les
émissions religieuses
c'est à la fois intéressant et à la fois
à mon avis je pense qu au ramadan la qui
commenceront pourrait plus faire ça ce
serait tout de suite repris récuser
polémique etc
je pense qu'on finalement on est devenu
beaucoup plus inquiet polémique sur les
religions que qu'il ya quelques années
isabelle de gaulmyn des émissions
religieuses à la télévision publique en
france c'est un peu contestable pour
pour un pays comme comme le nôtre qui
prône la laïcité
la laïcité c'est pas la neutralité de
l'état ça veut dire simplement que c'est
la neutralité de l'état mais pas la
neutralité de la france c'est à dire que
l'état est neutre mais il assure la
possibilité pour tous les français
d'exprimer leur religion et d'exercer
leur religion
donc c'est une manière de le faire et
comme il ya quand même beaucoup de
français est d'ailleurs de plus en plus
qu'ils ne peuvent plus se déplacer
je pense notamment aux personnes âgées
il suffit d'aller dans les ehpad pour
voir combien le jour du seigneur et
regardez je pense que c'est très
important aujourd'hui pour le lien
social et pour les plus anciens d'avoir
ses possibilités de religion à la
télévision je pense que là où on est
vraiment dans le service public c'est
c'est légal que sa cabine oui c'est
légal en tout cas c est un choix libre
pour une chaîne privée mais c'est une
obligation pour le service public douce
et dimanche matin sur france 2
de 8h30 à 12h
des missions religieuses qui
s'enchaînent des émissions qui sont sous
la responsabilité des représentants de
ces cultes voilà la religion à la
télévision merci beaucoup camille pour
ce dossier
et merci à vous et isabelle de gaulmyn
rédactrice en chef du journal la croix
voilà avant de refermer c'est inattendu
notre traditionnel pépite
cette semaine c'est une archive de 1966
en cette période de déclaration fiscale
vous allez voir qu'elle tombe à pic vous
pouvez chanter avec le monsieur est
aussi celle qui s'appelle je crois le
joyeux percept moi j'ai le corps en
vacances je suis toujours de bonne
humeur
euh vous pouvez me faire confiance je
suis toujours plein d'accord avec ça en
vacances je suis toujours de bonne
humeur
vraiment j'ai de la chance je suis le
choix yeux percepteur
[Rires]
voilà on se retrouve très vite à 22h sur
le canal 27 et toute la semaine bien sûr
sur les réseaux sociaux que ce soit ceux
de l'ina ou ceux de france info émission
préparée avec nos documentaliste si
précieuse anne delavaux laurence made
you lie merci à elle et merci à vous
d'être là
[Musique]